foreign
[Music]
the launch of a public inquiry to look
at how and why we got there this was an
essential step to ensure transparency
and accountability
during the inquiry I welcome the
opportunity to appear and to answer the
commission's questions as did all my
colleagues the work of the commission
and everyone involved was very important
not only to better understand what
happened a year ago
but to have a road map going forward for
any future governor
today the public order emergency
commission stated that the very high
threshold to invoke the emergencies Act
was met
he found that what we experienced last
year was a National Emergency that
threatened the security of Canadians
our job as a government is always to
keep people safe and invoking the
emergencies Act was the necessary thing
to do to remove the threat
and protect people
involvement through a lot over these
past years
Canadians and stressed face real
Financial challenges and lost loved ones
many people came to Ottawa because they
were hurting and wanted to be hurt
in our country everyone has the right to
protest peacefully that's a fundamental
right
because government will always defend
here in Ottawa people are used to
political activity and protests on
Parliament Hill
but as the commissioner said
lawful protests descended into
lawlessness
culminated in a national emergency
streets were blockaded in our capital
city for weeks causing serious harm to
families and small businesses
the immediate person the family is
the federal blockade Circle it is
in Alberta
guns were found at the blockade there
was a real risk to people promoting
ideologically motivated violent
extremism could act out or that they
could Inspire others to act out against
their fellow citizens
the situation was volatile and out of
control
the emergencies act provided us with
more tools to safely bring the illegal
blockades and occupations
to an end
let's be clear
we didn't want to have to invoke the
emergencies Act
it's a measure of Last Resort
but the risk to personal safety
the risk to livelihoods and equally the
risk of people losing faith in the rule
of law that upholds our society and our
freedoms
those risks were real
responsible leadership
required us to restore peace and Order
is
National
it is
foreign
provides a comprehensive objective
account of what happened and it also
provides recommendations
within the next year our government will
issue a comprehensive public response to
the commissioner's recommendations
because of the thoughtful work of the
commission there are lessons for
everyone involved law enforcement
agencies all orders of government and
elected officials
we will take seriously what the
commissioner concludes and what he
proposes
responsible leadership means that we are
always striving to do the very best for
Canadians in words and in Deeds
yes
the compassion
two days ago it was Flag Day
we celebrated the fact that 58 years ago
the maple leaf was raised over
Parliament Hill for the very first time
when I look at the Canadian flag I see
hope I see people who work hard every
day I see a country that has overcome
tremendous challenges
there's a reason why Canada is one of
the most successful democracies in the
world
it's because we work at it
it's not always easy actually sometimes
it can be pretty hard
but it's worth it
here in Ottawa
this Parliament the Senate the Supreme
Court these are not only old buildings
they're the institutions that protect
our rights and freedoms
this is something we must all continue
to care for
and defend
not just governments not just elected
leaders but all Canadians
our democracy is the responsibility of
all of us together
a healthy democracy
there's always going to make us stronger
especially in this moment of change and
Global uncertainty
so let's be there for one another
let's listen to and respect each other
even if we don't always agree
and let's continue to build a better
future
for all Canadians
thank you prime minister
we have 25 minutes for questions for
Media news
prime minister Kevin Gallagher CTV
national news so in his report judge
rule said that all levels of government
failed to put political partisanship
aside to really cooperate on the
emergency or crisis at hand prime
minister what responsibility do you take
for that failure
obviously the commissioner did excellent
work looking at all the different
factors that brought us to a place of
emergency
a place where
Canada had no choice but to use a
rarely never used provision that was
created 30 years ago
I think we all have
to make sure we are reflecting on
what to take away from that I certainly
know
that
we do better when we all work together
through the pandemic
different orders of government work
together extremely well to keep
Canadians safe that helped Canadians
we're working together right now on
Health Care
that's good for Canadians
during the emergencies act there were
certainly things we all could have done
more to work together and we will
absolutely be reflecting on those
for my follow-up on the freezing of
financial assets and this is maybe
something that also your Finance
Minister could answer as well
um you know in the report there was
though the freezing of financial assets
was described as appropriate and
effective uh there were concerns
failures he said not having a de-listing
mechanism for example for those who have
left the protest that was a failure also
joint accounts for maybe one's spouse
was not involved or connected to the
demonstration so you know does the
government owe those people who were
wrapped up and had their financial
assets Frozen but were not involved with
the protest an apology or compensation
those were a very important
considerations so we're pleased that the
government that the commission
highlighted but I can tell you they were
part of our deliberations as well and as
you say the commissioner determined that
those measures were appropriate and
useful uh in this context
absolutely there are things to learn on
how to do this better if ever a
government has to face a similar
situation
but we were incredibly thoughtful about
how to make sure we could end this
challenging situation as quickly and as
safely as possible and that's where the
commissioner coming out and saying that
this was appropriate and effective is a
good thing not just for the government
but for Canadians confidence that our
institutions are able to handle
difficult situations I'm happy to turn
to the Deputy Prime Minister
so look when it comes to the financial
measures I think the most important
thing to start with is as the Prime
Minister just said Justice rulo's
conclusion which was and I'm going to
read it
it was a powerful tool to discourage
participation and to incentivize
protesters to leave I am satisfied that
it played a meaningful role in shrinking
the footprint of the protests and in
doing so made a meaningful contribution
to resolving the public order emergency
that is his broad conclusion on the
economic measures it's what we believed
at the time and I'm really glad that
having looked at this so carefully
Justice Rulo agrees I would also add
that what was so important for us in
putting in place these economic measures
was our overriding objective of course
was to end the illegal blockades and
occupation it was to do so without
violence without anyone being hurt and
the economic measures were a tool that
really helped make that happen on the
specific question about unfreezing
accounts Justice Rulo also points out
a couple of things he points out that on
February 21st an order issue a statement
from the RCMP
effectively instructed that all accounts
be unfrozen of course when the measures
were lifted on February 23rd they were
unfrozen and he also pointed out in his
own report that work was done
urgently at the time and was being done
between the government and law
enforcement bodies and Banks
to ensure that there was a process in
place to unfreeze the accounts so all of
that was happening as the Prime Minister
said
in the very
horrible event
that this ever has to happen again for
sure there are some lessons for us
thank you
prime minister Ryan Thomas the National
Post
the the commissioner said that your
government was justified in invoking the
ACT but it also says that invoking the
ACT should have been avoided he's quite
clear in that front and that he says it
was a failure of federalism as well as a
failure of policing I'm wondering if you
think that more should have been done
that you should have gotten involved
earlier to avoid having to invoke the
ACT
um
obviously
um it took failures it took systems that
weren't able to solve a situation that
ideally would have been able to solve by
a robust set of Institutions and
principles like we have in Canada
that we would need to invoke an
emergencies Act
it is unfortunate it was undesirable we
didn't want to do it but we got into a
place where there was no other choice
to keep Canadians safe we felt then to
do this and that's what we did and
indeed the commissioner found that yes
we met that very high bar there should
be a very high bar
for invoking emergencies act and we hit
that
um
in looking at all the lessons to be
learned so that we don't have to hit
that high bar again so that we can deal
with situations of emergency there are
many lessons and obviously as a federal
government we will continue to do
everything we can to work
collaboratively
across orders of government with
Partners in the provinces and
territories work with municipalities and
make sure we are
able to deal with the challenges that
are coming at us I think there are
reflections for other orders of
government as well as what they can draw
from this commissioner's report and I
certainly recommend all of my fellow
first ministers to read this report
carefully
the commissioner also suggested in his
recommendations that the emergencies act
should be Rewritten in some very key
areas I'm wondering you talked about
reviewing it but is your government
committed to rewriting the act at least
in some fashion
um I think we've all we all were very
very aware that this was an act that was
written 30 years ago and
I do appreciate that the commissioner
um
praised quite highly
the parliamentarians and the government
of the day 30 years ago that put
together an act that
has a level of accountability and
transparency
like having a full public inquiry on
invocation of the ACT
um
I think it's a credit to the work that
those parliamentarians did 30 years ago
but obviously there are things that need
to change in it the first one we did it
didn't even occur to us to when we were
sitting down to meet the premiers that
we wouldn't include the territorial
premiers
but that's not written into the act that
you have to include the premiums of the
territories obviously that should be
included in the ACT uh also 30 years ago
the understanding of the need for
partnership and consultation with
indigenous peoples wasn't as strong
um we did some consultation and
engagement with indigenous peoples but
it should be formalized and we probably
should have done more as well so these
are things that absolutely we look to
improving as we move forward as we look
at the ACT but we will take the proper
time to analyze these recommendations we
know the commissioner and his team put a
lot of work into formulating these
recommendations and we're going to take
them very seriously and look at them
very carefully before we make too many
pronouncements on the changes that we
look forward to making with all
parliamentarians next question Global
Mail Steve Chase with the Globe and Mail
good afternoon I would like to change
the subject for a minute
to the 2021 elections
as reported in the globe mail today
ceases has evidence that the Chinese
government interfered in the 2021
elections my question for you is when
the government learned of this why
didn't didn't they expel
the Chinese government diplomats
involved
I have been saying for years including
on the floor of the House of Commons
that China
is trying to interfere
in our democracy in the processes in our
country including
during our elections
we are aware of this and I can assure
you
that our intelligence and security
agencies have been working very hard
over the past many years
to develop more and more tools to
counter this to make sure that our
institutions are kept safe
this is not a new phenomenon this is
something that countries around the
world have been grappling with for a
long time and Canada is no exception
but what I think is also really
important to say
is that for the 2019 and for the 2021
elections and for elections going
forward
this government created
a panel of top civil servants
who would lean on all the information
provided to them by our security
agencies like csis to ensure
foreign
that interference by Foreign Afters does
not affect
the running or the outcomes of our
elections and I can emphasize once again
that Canada has some of the best and
most robust elections in the world
and all Canadians can have total
confidence
that the outcomes of the 2019 and the
2021 elections were determined by
Canadians and Canadians alone at the
voting booth foreign
foreign
selector
is foreign
foreign
we reported on today they talk about for
instance the uh Consul General in
Vancouver bragging about how they
defeated two MPS to conservative MPS
there are countless examples in there of
Chinese interference why did this task
force you're talking about not tell
Canada anything about this
and what happened to your foreign
registry
um
we have like I said known for a long
time
that China and others
engage in foreign interference in Canada
including during our elections
and certainly the fact that a Chinese
Diplomat would try to take credit for
things that would happen is not
something that is unseen in diplomatic
circles around the world
the fact is
that the work that ceases has done
including with our election Integrity
panel headed up by our top
public servants
has
will always ensure that any risks to our
election or to the Integrity of those
elections get highlighted to Canadians
next question is
[Music]
foreign
recognition
following today's report do you have any
regrets about Colleen Ottawa protesters
a French minority
yeah I wish I had said that differently
um
I you know as I look back on that and
and you know as I've reflected on it
over over the past months not just
um freshly from this commissioner's
report
I I wish I had phrased it differently
the fact is there is a very small number
of people in this country
who deliberately
spread misinformation and disinformation
that led to Canadians deaths
that led to excessive hardship in people
who believed them
I
continue to be very
very firm against those individuals
but that is a small subset of people who
were just hurting
and worried
and wanting to be heard
and as much as I tried to emphasize
throughout the time that of course we're
always going to stand up for freedom of
speech and freedom to protest peacefully
um
I wish I hadn't said something that was
able to be spread larger if I had chosen
my words a bit careful have been more
specific I think things might have been
a bit easier yeah
Ouija regret uh
[Music]
leader
um
a
job foreign
foreign
in your opening remarks you mentioned
that um the government will deal with
the recommendations within the year but
one of the recommendations is to have
actually a plan in place within the next
six months of how you're going to deal
with the recommendations can you at
least to commit to having a plan in
place within the next six months yes
uh
foreign
um
[Music]
foreign
Quebec
uh
Deputy key
come to deputies
the conversations
questions
foreign
me
Governors decision
is
olations
foreign
[Music]
vaccine
a
on Via
effective
in particular population
is
foreign
[Music]
definition but reflections
utilization
[Music]
the the confusion deliberations
Liberty
zone is
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
[Music]
expired
uses a
honest
diversity
the
regime the perspective
is
a result
I think
the first thing I'd say to people who
joined
these these protests these occupations
is first of all
they will always have a right to be
heard to express themselves to protest
peacefully things they disagree with
and they have been hurt
um
they've expressed very clearly
their views their perspectives and their
hurt
at the same time however we are a
government
that is grounded in science and data
and expert advice and we followed
the advice of Public Health officers and
medical professionals
keep Canadians safe during a pandemic
that include encouraging through every
means we could people to get vaccinated
and that worked
we had a
better pandemic than many of our peer
countries with fewer deaths
with lower levels of economic disruption
with greater social cohesion than many
other places
and we will continue
to listen to All voices across this
wonderfully diverse country that isn't
just diverse geographically or or
culturally or in Origins but also in
perspectives
but listening to each other
goes in both directions
we hear their skepticism around science
but they need to also hear our belief in
science
these are conversations that we need to
have not to say of course that everyone
who
chose not to get vaccinated doesn't
believe in science of course not
individuals could make decisions for
themselves
and we'll always respect that
but those individuals who deliberately
chose to amplify falsehoods and put
their fellow citizens at risk
those those were things that a
government needs to stand firmly against
because our job is
to keep Canadians safe
that's what we did during this
emergencies act that's what we did
during this pandemic that's what we will
continue to do press